so one of the things we're interested in
studying the monkeys for is because we
want to see do they have the kinds of
cognitive capacities that we have as
humans that we're really proud of and
one of these things is what we call a
theory of mind
it's complicated term but what it really
just means is the fact that when we look
out in the world and watch human
behavior we don't see just behavior we
see all these things going on inside the
head so we see other people's beliefs
their intentions their desires that's
how we kind of make sense of the world
it's a hard problem from a psychology
perspective because we can't see any of
that stuff directly or making all these
kind of crazy inferences about what's
going on in others heads so lots of
researchers have wondered do other
animals do this can they go beyond what
they see and actually infer other things
the way we've tried to get at this is a
little bit tricky we've said well what
are the contexts in which other species
might use a theory of mind if they had
them and the sad thing is that if you
think about evolution usually the way
other species might use a theory of mind
is actually to out-compete others to
deceive others to do kind of slightly
dastardly things with what they know
about others beliefs and intentions so
we set up a big series of studies at the
field site to actually see do the
monkeys know when it's a good time to
deceive us in other words do they pay
attention to what we can see and what we
know so the experiment is pretty simple
we set up a human who has some treat
that a monkeys might like like a piece
of grape and we just vary whether the
human can see the grape you know so he's
either facing it or he's turned around
he's a barrier in front of his face
and what we do is just ask you know does
a monkey subject try to steal it and
what we find is surprisingly the monkeys
use pretty much the same cues that
humans used to decide when somebody
could see them so they don't steal a
great for somebody's facing forward but
they do if somebody has turned to the
side or looking away so they're they're
very good cheats and thieves but in in
showing that they're good cheats and
thieves we've actually been able to see
they have some aspects of our own theory
of mind